[Music]
um
you're glowing oh thank you
i use aloe and river slime to maintain
my no look
oh this this is my little sister apple's
magic i got the clown
your little sister's magic yeah every
dragon has a unique magic oh okay what's
yours
i'm a really strong swimmer
wait wait wait wait wait you touched
this gem piece and it gave you powers
you know what this means right i no
longer need a nightlight what
no you're so connected to the gems magic
and that means you can still use it to
save the world
if we can get all the other gem pieces
you can reassemble it and boom the drone
away
and bring my bob back and bring all of
kumandra back
who was that girl that's namari she's
the backstabbing venturi
wow those cats are really fast huh
what do captain drone have in common um
they
have no salt and they both hate
water
welcome to the world famous shrimp oreo
my name is boone
i'll be your server today would you like
to hear our daily specials yes please we
got shrimp we got kanji we got a shrimp
kanji that won't quit
the captain where is the captain let me
go get him
what's up my new customers i'm captain
boone
the owner chef and chief financial
officer of the shrimp oreo
how can i help you well i'm sisu and we
need to get to talon
now i'm sorry the shrimp oreo is not a
water taxi
toy that's a lot of jake half now half
when we arrive in town
deal class sponsor kanji today's special
is
to go
did you just hit me with a shrimp tail
when were you gonna tell us she was
season
uh well technically you always knew she
was
seriously why are you here divine water
dragon
in that obvious big guy my girl ryan and
i are gonna fix the world
bring everyone back you're gonna bring
everyone back
i wanna help i'm sorry i i can't let you
do that
it's too dangerous you're not the only
one who
lost family to the drone
please let me help you
[Music]
i too wish to join this fellowship of
drone but
[Music]
chicory
[Music]
all right guys remember what we're
looking for and don't
trust anyone
hey baby where are your parents
hey uh who's baby
really a con baby
impressive we could use someone like you
let's catch you up my name is raya
our lands have been at war for as long
as we can remember
our people never see eye to eye
my daughter i believe our people can
come together again
but someone has to take the first step
now in order to restore peace
we must find the last dragon i wish to
join this fellowship of butt
hickory let's go
we'll have to watch our backs
we're not the only ones looking
six years of searching please let this
be it
almighty sees you who said that
we really need your help ah i'm gonna be
real with you i'm not like the best
dragon have you ever done like a group
project but there's like that one kid
who didn't pitch in as much but
still ended up with the same grave uh
we're doomed
you and the dragon are coming with me
hmm my sword here says we're not
the world's broken
you can't trust anyone
maybe it's broken because you don't
trust anyone
you just have to take the first step
i just changed dragons can do that look
how close my butt is to my head
it's gonna make digestion so much faster
in theaters or ordered on disney plus
with premier access
march 5th
why are you here to find water dragon
in that obvious big guy my girl ryan and
i are gonna fix the world
let's catch you up it is so
exciting to be the first southeast asian
disney princess
it is big deal ryan is one of the
fiercest characters
[Music]
in ryan the last dragon we were inspired
by things about southeast asia to create
a
holy original story and fantasy world
called kumandra
this land used to be inhabited by
mystical dragons which brought magic
and harmony but over time the land split
apart
our lands have been at war for as long
as we can remember
and now she's on this mission to bring
this world back together with this
ragtag group of misfits
i wish to join this fellowship of
particularly
the animation on this movie is on a
totally different level and it's amazing
when you think
that this movie was animated from home
it's incredible
you know we have a crew of 400 plus
people we were
animating lighting having story meetings
all of that was done from everyone's
home with dogs and cats and babies
yeah it could only have happened because
everybody is passionate about the films
we make and they brought that
i mean the movie is i think one of our
most beautiful films
you and the dragon are coming with me
my sword here says we're not
i have the honor of being one of the
martial arts consultants on the film
i got to incorporate the knowledge i had
from southeast asian martial arts
into those fight sequences you see
weapons get pulled out from
raya that are screama that come from the
philippines
when you see why uh toronto fights that
you could go that's our knees
that's mutai that's crabby crabbons
the level of action in this movie is
pretty tight it's pretty tight
the world's broken you can't trust
anyone i think the themes of this movie
are so relevant
maybe it's broken because you don't
trust anyone learning how to find the
goodness in the world i think is such a
beautiful important message
i really just can't wait for people to
see it
hi i'm kelly marie tran
i'm playing raya in raya and the last
dragon and these
are my video diaries i'm going to give
you
a tour of the makeshift voiceover booth
that i've been using at home
so here's the microphone recording from
home has been really fun
but there's been some hard things
especially with having internet that's
always
freezing it could be really frustrating
when you're in the middle of a really
good take and then all of a sudden
just kidding that was awesome give me
some shelf
whoa it looks so good i am so
just inspired by how many people are
working on this
from home our actors including you have
been so gracious letting us not only
into their home
into their closets so that we can record
together i'm about to watch the trailer
for the first time
okay
my name is raya
i'm realizing that i might have always
been a disney kid exhibit
a exhibit b
exhibit c so it's pretty crazy that
now i get to be a disney princess
that's pretty crazy today i'm at walt
disney animation studios this is
actually where i auditioned um so it's
crazy to be back here
i'll always remember the first time that
we met you we did that recording kelly
because we had found the voice and the
heart behind the character
the best time truly oh i love you guys
you're getting a little too big for this
bud
i can't wait for you guys to see this
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
give me some shell i gotcha
[Applause]
aah
my whole life i trained to become a
guardian of the dragon gem
but this world has changed
and its people are divided
now to restore peace i must find
the last dragon
my name is raya
[Music]
you're getting a little too big for this
[Music]
bud
[Music]
you